uses to travel the world and it's
powered by these power moons so you keep
needing additional thresholds of them to
get on to the next Kingdom and just to
show off a little bit of the new moves
obviously it's the Hat throw you can
make it stay in place which is sometimes
the valuable it can grab things for you
there's two kinds of coins which I'll
talk about it a little later on actually
there in that will dialogue box who saw
Kathy oh yeah yeah
Kathy is both the Red Hat that he's
wearing and also in his native form he's
a white top hat and so one other move
that's pretty cool is this circular
throw not to weigh everything but let's
get down into the city and as you saw on
the trailer so there's the the capture
mechanic lets you take over things it
also lets you do fairly exotic things
like turn into electricity travel to
walk so how did the capture mechanic
come about it'll capture to your shields
the Kakaako I'm not an official so is it
close a cooler what was the book we
don't know cause she's had to kill more
it does stick out up the sturdiness so
when we were making this game before we
started out doing was making just a huge
amount of different gameplay prototypes
it'll capture the actual solution or
still to this and this capture action
was just one of those prototypes a
minute ago idea that she not only did
expand the scale of all so dope
so say it's an eg great it's good
they're also they've got emotional -
emotional background a pseudo game run
or choosing idiotic so you know it was
just one of the ideas that came up but
we worked on it for two or three days
and it just instantly turned into
something that was really fun and we
decided well okay this should just be to
the center of this game I love how much
it encourages that exploration and
experimentation that I think the Mario
games along these lines are so known for
about Super Mario 64 Super Mario
Sunshine here we've got so much stuff
that just looks interesting and you're
wondering okay what will happen if I
throw my cap at it you never really know
what's gonna happen so you want to try
everything just to see non-journal
tennis team attack Anaru
shield his name also god so say you
don't know what you call [ __ ] nugget
thing
yeah I definitely hope my people while
they're playing this game they just
forever have of everything and pride all
sorts of different things that one thing
right now normally if you're following
the story path of the game you'd be
talking to Mayor Pauline who wants you
to recruit musicians there's one there
but we're going to ignore that right now
because there's lots and lots of things
to be on following the main story of the
game like possess rockets and turn into
rockets with Mustang if you could
actually that's an interesting note
there so you mentioned that mayor
Pauline and I think our sharp-eyed
viewers will have noticed that some of
the street signs are references to some
Donkey Kong characters we've got some
interesting red girders going on here I
wonder um Jesus I don't want to cross
not if you can tell us a little bit more
about the cities that's an interesting
backstory the partying on podiums each
other is there and for you dong city to
you Nana got a parrot or many cards
cannot receive a day sets many props so
das net ha no ha my masala sushi burrito
don t come on Cara Santa Monica no GE
Kinkaid ah re so let's go Joe that was
good Elias kiddo
so certainly it's from Donkey Kong and
the name new Dark City probably leads
you to a couple of hints but we can't
get into too much of it I like the shirt
you're wearing by the way that is a
snatch it's honestly we need please look
forward to hearing more about that
oh and this is interesting here where we
see I mean really throughout New York
City next week throughout the world
we've got these really fun playground
elements where you're bouncing on things
you're jumping on things you're swinging
can you tell our viewers a little bit
more about how you came up with that
kind of play mechanical game Buddhist
are fish there in toto behind that HDMI
you don't know it's all conch you on the
money like angles as it is invisible I
don't want to do you food I'll show you
like that
so bebop we different yeah that's it
really comes I got Scott high wasn't
such a good feeling it was it'll fit
players of yours customers so they were
poor height stairs digital all it's
pretty much puzzle so now going back to
that prototyping process I was talking
about before we obviously create lots
and lots of different ones laughing lots
of different game ideas and then next
what we think about is where to place
them within a space so funny Salado
there is no path without taking over the
wall what's it did I also did it was so
you know we put in the stage we like
combine it with different art assets
like kind of like real real things to
see what it might actually look like a
work in game and then try playing sort
of a motocross Tai Tokerau no you don't
like it identical no this so those are
any so funny when I searched it it's
good things and then you know obviously
out of that like different things come
up like oh maybe we could do this a
little bit differently maybe this could
actually work like this instead and then
we kind of add that to it and the
process just continues from there but
it's a chaotic scene and go jumps I said
no more no Super Mario Sunshine about
totally died on the shield after this so
you talk Ocala to take him to a TV in US
and so you know you saw before you know
we were able to jump on top of the taxi
and that's something that was sort of in
Super Mario Sunshine at time so in that
way we're also getting hints from past
games can I quickly interject that in
the so as I mentioned the goal right now
is to recruit these musicians when I was
first playing this game for a feedback
report for the development team I could
not figure out how to get to this guy on
the top of this building you can just
barely see him he's a speck right now in
that triangular building and the way I
eventually found to do it was to take a
real
that works a bit to my surprise and I
would already know when you when you saw
that report from me you know what was
was that a problem to be solved was that
a cool thing what was that like ammonia
Juana and Ciaran the whole food shop
activity occurring SUNY and traffic to
note on denominator check at Ignacio to
Python Atticus Audra so let me take
total commodity thundershock hi so no
you all done this gay little more
although you're not discreditable talk
over the present Oh what about it
yeah I did read that I didn't know
you're gonna be playing that right now
troublemaker
Liverpool well I also do the real way
I'm just another way he'll achieve
indigo you don't apprentice Capello have
I stammered a terrible horrible
SuperMario it's really a sleepover it's
a shame that this is kamala data worries
but you know you found your own way to
play it and like you know letting users
you know play around with the game and
find their own ways of doing things
that's something that you know goes way
back in 3d Mario in Super Mario 64 and
Super Mario Sunshine as well so this is
actually one of the two kingdoms going
to be playable on the show floor the
show floor course isn't open yet so we
don't have folks playing the game at
this moment but I'm really looking
forward to talking to folks after they
played it because I think there's so
many different ways to problem solve and
find the moons and these kingdoms I'm
not even sure folks will find everything
over the course of the showbiz going to
be interesting to find out how different
people approached completing some of
these objectives but the game encourages
it so much experimentation because
you're kicked out of the level when
every point every time you find a moon
there is no reason not to investigate
every little thing you can see that
might be interesting but that time limit
there's no there's no disincentive
lots and lots of cool stuff whoa yeah it
is a very interesting change that adds I
think to be immersion in the kingdoms
when you think about Super Mario 64
Super Mario Sunshine
whenever you got your whatever the
collective objective was depending on
the game you're playing I could get
bumped out of the area and you'd have to
come back in but here since you're not
going to get rooted out the kingdom in
the collective power moon there's a lot
of encouragement to just go go check out
that weird thing you saw on the horizon
because you can still continue with
whatever you're then you know keep on
tracking and finding moves
another reason to explore everything is
that there's very little distance
there's very little punishment for dying
I just lost 10 coins and there's lots so
and I get to try again right away
mr. Bitcoin it's also worth mentioning
that the bullet bills here are coming
out with visors on so they cannot be
captured Lee knock their hats off an
enemy with a hat is the scariest thing
in this game fashion is very important
you got to be conscious of your head
where well apparently this is not my day
for this challenge
that's right third time's a charm right
yeah and if you if at first you don't
succeed give up on the third attempt
I'm just looking at the space where we
saw other sections of you dog city and
looking here I'm just so impressed with
the texture work that's been done and I
feel like every time I see me build this
game more and more of these textures
just jumping out at me it's it's really
fun to see you personally it is a
gorgeous game and we're going to we have
some other segments later on in the in
the stream that are going to highlight
some especially pretty areas oh you got
this and oh well it could be my fingers
and toes crossed yes one thing that we
haven't mentioned yet that we probably
should talk a little bit about is the
fact that you're playing with joy bond
with the wrist wraps attached just and
that's a really fantastic way to play
this game and of course supports pro
controller and other controller options
but you can do so much with the motion
controls and throwing Kathy feels very
intuitive yeah I'm going to switch to a
different section of game where I showed
the sand world which is also playable on
the show floor so give me just